Steve here again my wife and I have just
come out of Jordan we had a day and a
half there wonderful experience I'm
going to show you a few shots of our
experience visiting Petra which is a
wonderful site both in terms of history
and culture and nature and stuff and
just a couple of comments here as we get
ready to head back home after our trip
one of the things is his discovery of
Greece the friendliness the hospitality
there the second thing was the the fact
that the Greek language is such a big
part of the culture here even at Petra
which was you know a site which was
treated by the Nabataeans in Arabic
group some you know 2000 years ago they
were in touch with the Roman world at
the time which is in fact Greek skete
speaking and it's just that while we've
been to Crete we've been to Greece we've
been now to Israel and Jordan so the
Greek thing ties it all together that
was just one observation the other
observation was we had an excellent taxi
driver in Jordan who picked us up at the
border and took us to Petra and helped
us you know get around in Petra in Wadi
Musa and then droves back to the border
he speaks very good English he has a
business he gets recommendations on
TripAdvisor on the Internet his name is
Hamza I'll put the the link here but hey
he's a very nice man very conscientious
he keeps his car very clean but he
speaks English well so that sets him
apart from all the other drivers and it
just reminded me again of the importance
of language up there too a lot of the
little children who were selling things
were you know calling out in Italian or
German or Russian so language is so
important and but I particularly thought
of it in with reference to Hamza who is
creating a business because aside from
being a very conscientious
you know worker in his field he speaks
English so communication matters and
probably the next time I do a video I'll
be back home in Canada
now hi there I've just finished climbing
quite a long way pretty aggressive climb
and I'm at what's I think it's the
monastery and there's another viewpoint
up here I'm at Petra I wasn't sure what
to expect here it's been it's amazing
it's amazing the scale of it the this an
ancient arabic collar pre-islamic
civilization we see the influence of
other civilizations similar in that
sense to what we saw Konoe souls that
contact with their Greeks and Egypt and
other parts of the Middle East all
contributed to to this community that
lived here and you know it's so been so
fascinating to connect the dots I have
made the Egypt but of course see some of
the civilizations on in what is called
the Middle East or not the most ancient
one connections with Greece
there's engravings in the rock here that
are in Aramaic and Greek and connections
with Rome of course the Romans at that
time were Greek speaking and of course
the Acropolis so it's all been amazing
unfortunate speak Arabic so just as in
Israel I'm not really able to
communicate that well but the people
here seem to be quite good in languages
Italian or english-speaking or whatever
and offer them their wares in their
language I'm going out to the lookout
now and then I left my wife down with
the donkey guy who led me halfway up
here and gonna go back and join them
riding the donkey that's another skill
that I have to acquire because it's
difficult to maintain your balance when
he's going up the hill okay that's
enough for now
[Music]
[Music]
you